the injury of a police officer of course
remains of the bravery of our Police
Service and the run towards danger as
the rest of us would run away and I want
to express my thanks to the police for
what appears to me to be the very calm
and professional way that they responded
to this incident and undoubtedly ensured
that a very very serious incident didn't
become much worse but I want to thank
all of our emergency services because
they will all have contributed to the
response this afternoon at clearly
investigations are ongoing the police
have just confirmed that at this stage
they are not treating this as a
terrorist incident but of course there
are still details yet to be determined
and I would urge the public to follow
updates from police Scotland and not to
share information that is unconfirmed
this is a serious situation and none of
us need to make it worse by shielding
it's speculative accounts of what
happened discussions that you've had
with police Scotland and other agencies
I became aware literally the moment I
stepped off the podium having done the
daily update on the covert situation my
office was there waiting to tell me what
they knew at that time which was very
little over the course of the afternoon
I've had updates from the Justice
Secretary so it's booking directly with
the Chief Constable and the information
I'm able to share with you is
information that has been shared with me
by the Chief Constable and I've had a
conversation brief conversation with the
prime minister as well this afternoon
who wanted to obviously express his
concern and his sympathies to those
who've been caught up in this incident
this has been a dreadful afternoon for
the city of Glasgow and particularly for
those who have been directly involved
those injured obviously but there will
have been people who witnessed this
afternoon particularly in the location
of this incident quite horrific events
and I think I will not be alone across
Scotland tonight and thinking of
everybody who has in any way been
affected by what unfolded
you said you don't want people to
suspect you easily but we are hearing
reports that this involved a hotel where
asylum seekers have been housed and we
have seen protests in glass all over
asylum seekers rights last few days what
more can you say about that scoffs
refugee council saying of course people
are worried didn't and yes people have
an understanding of the location and
what that location has been used for in
in recent times but beyond that I don't
think it is helpful for people to
speculate clearly there have been some
tensions in Glasgow as there have been
in other parts of the UK in recent times
but I want to send a message to people
across Glasgow and across Scotland when
dreadful things like this happen they
shocked all of us to our core but above
all they should remind us of what unites
us and not what divides us Glasgow is my
home it's the city I live in it's the
city that I represent part of in the
Scottish Parliament people Glasgow are
wonderful people and I'm sure tonight
there will be a sense of coming together
in the city of Glasgow and all of us
reminding us what unites us as human
beings the whole country the whole world
is going through a really tough and
traumatic time at the moment and this is
an opportunity and it's a time to think
of each other and the care we owe each
other and that's what I think every
decent person across Glasgow will be
doing this evening
when else we're in Scotland regarding
that as we go into the weekend but let's
all keep calm people should not be
gathering together right now we live in
a democracy people have the right to
peaceful protest but we still face a
potentially deadly virus people should
not be gathering together but right now
in Glasgow in particular as well as the
threat from corvid we have six
individuals who are seriously ill in
hospital as a result of horrific
incident that's taken place so all of us
should bear them in mind be their
families in mind and focus on making
sure that we are thinking of all of
those great things that bring our city
together and I know so many people
across Glasgow and I know that's what
the majority
we'll be doing tonight thought should
first and foremost be with the six
individuals who are in hospital and our
thoughts and our gratitude should be
with our police officers particularly
that police officer who sustained
injuries trying to keep the rest of the
public safe and let's focus on thinking
of them and the police are seeing that
there is no immediate threat to the
public and what is your message to the
public this is an alarming situation
that's unfolded people may be very
worried about that well I think there's
two things to see beyond saying of
course people are what he did not say
these are incidents that shock all of us
and leave a sense of anxiety in their
aftermath and I understand that as I
raised it and a citizen of Glasgow I
share that as well as empathize with it
but I would say two things that the
police through their professionalism and
calm handling of this contained this
situation relatively quickly and you
know even as many of the other details
that we now know where didn't know him
the police were able to see that they
had contained the situation and there
was no ongoing threat to the public and
I think that's the first thing to see by
way of reassurance secondly we don't
know all of the details we don't know
what has given rise to this incident but
the police has just have just in the
last couple of minutes it confirmed that
their assessment know is that this is
not a terrorist related incident and I
hope that will give some of your
students to people not just in Glasgow
but across Scotland as you see the
police confirming it's not a terrorist
incident when do you expect to get
another update from the police what will
you be doing for the rest of this
afternoon and this evening will you be
making your way to Glasgow the police
have to be allowed to go on with the job
and I think can a situation like this
that's the most important thing I can do
my job as far as menaced is to make sure
they have all the support that they need
and I will expect to be kept updated on
an ongoing basis of any developments and
when an ongoing basis not just tonight
but over the weekend that if there is
information that needs to be shared with
the public that will be done by the
police or where appropriate by it by me
and by the government but this is a
situation that has undoubtedly shaken
Glasgow to the unshaken Scotland today
but the police have dealt with it that
is non going for it to the public the
assessment is
is not a terrorist related incident that
said there are six individuals in a
critical condition as a result of
injuries that they have sustained and
all of our thoughts and dude where she's
at this evening should be with him